The last time America created a new
military service was in 1947, when the
Air Force split off from the Army.
Seventy years later, the House of
Representatives has asked the Air Force
to reorganize and spin-off a new Space
Corps. But the result would not be akin
to the relationship between the Navy and
the Marines, as its supporters suggest.
That's because Congress would leave the
Space Corps with little beyond
navigation, GPS, and communication
satellites. It would not oversee vital
space operations including nuclear
strike, ballistic missile defense, or
anti-satellite missions. This "new" service
would be less "Space Corps" and more of a
"satellite force". The White House, Air
Force leadership, and the Secretary of
Defense have all spoken out against the
plan, and it's easy to see why: While it's
been touted as a way to compel the Air
Force to focus on space, all it would
really do is create more Pentagon
bureaucracy. Instead, it's best for
Congress to work with the Air Force to
strengthen our existing Space Command.
Let's keep America's Space Marines
relegated to science fiction.
To learn more about my take on why Congress should kill the Space Corps,
check out the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you want
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to subscribe for more research
and videos from AEI.